what are the differences and also the
similarities of film sitcom television
writing versus reality TV writing how
are they different how are they the same
all forms of television are the same in
that you need to follow an acceptable
structure people need to understand
what's happening and you need to have a
progression of action that's the
simplest part if you're talking about
sitcoms or dramas or reality shows or in
any however they're supposed to come
across whatever the mood of the pieces
no matter what the tone is every act
break is going to have to give you
something that's unresolved or it's
going to make what you want to come back
from the break same deal in scripted
same deal and drama it's harder to do in
reality because naturally in life there
aren't a lot of cliffhangers it's one of
the reasons why as a dip when you talk
about the difference in reality
television reality television is the
only genre on television that typically
uses teasers or bumpers or shows you
what's coming after the commercial
because we can't always end on that like
the moment where you're waiting for
something to happen so we have to show
you this thing that makes it seems like
a non sequitur at the time where it's
like the glass is breaking and someone's
going like Larry well I want to come
back because I want to know what that is
you know I couldn't end on the scene
that ends sort of benignly at the end of
the thing we have to tack that on other
real difference is i don't i just i
truly don't see very many i truly don't
see very many story has the same
components in reality that has
inscripted the only difference is when
you're missing a piece you don't have
the luxury of going ex nihilo and
creating a situation from nothing
because your cast members it has to be
authentic to them you sometimes have to
figure out a way to tweak things that
already exist in order for you know in
order to clarify a point or add some
interview content to help you
contextualize the material properly
but I saw that again it's it's all story
it's all the same
you